fin du congrès du parti communiste
aujourd'hui à saint point pas de
surprise georges marchais reste
secrétaire général
pas de surprise non plus pierre juquin
dit le bureau politique reste
l'évolution de la composition du comité
central qui est le parlement du parti
là on voit que les débats ont été serrés
et que les dosages ont été savant michel
naudy comment réduire la contestation
sans que l'opération chirurgicale ne se
traduise par une trop forte c'est nier
c'est l'équation qu'a eu à résoudre le
congrès du parti communiste et
singulièrement sa direction le
traitement choisies et à doses variables
pour pierre juquin c'est l'éviction du
bureau politique a sorti du maintien au
comité central
pour marcel rigaud et félix da mais tu
sais la réélection comité central mais
accommoder d'un sérieux avertissement
ils ont été abondamment relayée par deux
à trois cents délégués pour les autres
ce que ne protégeait pas la notoriété ou
une opposition nette à la direction
c'est la sortie des organismes
dirigeants hélas la liste est symbolique
alain amis kabyle les marques d'amitié
pour la meurthe et moselle
hélène constant pour la haute-vienne
françois ce ainsi pour la seine saint
denis la plus grande fédération de
france daniel lacroix pour renault
billancourt
d'autres encore jusqu'au directeur de
l'école des cadres du parti communiste
quant à ceux qui furent sauvés in
extremis
georges marchais l'oracle et au monde
délimiter le terrain ses camarades ne
sont pas élus parce qu'ils sont en
désaccord et que ceux ci doivent être
exprimées au sein de la direction
ils sont réélus malgré leurs désaccords
et parce que le congrès pense que notre
parti à la force
la maturité nécessaire pour faire face à
cette situation
effectivement sans précédent à ce niveau
et pour la faire évoluer positivement
tout se passe en vérité comme si on
avait conservé quelques branches en
prenant soin de couper les racines
la cause est entendue
- pour l'immédiat la démarche
programmatique et exclut la notion de
gauche critique et l'union devient
circonstanciel et le secrétaire général
demeure fidèle au poste pour le reste
georges marchais l'a dit lui même c'est
la pratique qui tranchera